[Musique]
et si on commençait par regarder un
extrait d'une série qui a des millions
de fans
deux forums
j'ai pris ce nom
[Musique]
alors je sais pas pour vous mais moi
j'ai vu une scène de viol peut-être que
pour certains et certaines dans la salle
c'est pas aussi clair peut-être que vous
avez vu cersei cette reine qui est très
amoureuse de jay-z lannister qui est
aussi son frère pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ne connaissent pas game of thrones
l'inceste c'est cool
et puis elle est aussi tiraillé parce
que peut-être que à côté d'elle il ya
son fils qui est mort
enfin je devrais dire leur fils qu'ils
ont eu un fils ensemble et si vous
n'êtes pas sûr mais c'est peut-être
normal puisque le réalisateur de cet
épisode et l'acteur qui joue jamila ni
stars au nom puis sont pas vraiment sur
le réalisateur dit que pour lui
au début c'est une scène de viol mais à
la fin il bien consentement et quand on
demande à l'acteur alors est ce que
c'est une scène de viol lui il répond
oui et non alors le viol c'est pas oui
et non en fait quand une femme dit non
et qu'elle ait pénétré
ça s'appelle un viol alors comment
est-ce que ça se fait que dans cette
série que tout le monde regarde on
montre une scène de viol comme un acte
de sexe banal on en arrive là parce que
depuis les années 1930 à hollywood en a
pris l'habitude de montrer les femmes
comme des objets de désir qu'on peut
prendre penser aux années 50 et à
marilyn monroe dans sept ans de
réflexion la manière dont sa robe se
soulève et on voit ses jambes
pensez à fenêtre sur cour et la manière
dont grace kelly va être toujours
observé par cet appareil photo ce regard
voyeuriste
pensez aussi à brigitte bardot qui
dansent de manière merveilleuse dans et
dieu créa la femme
et puis hop a tout d'un coup il faut
qu'on voit sa culotte noire parce que si
fokker la jupe elle s'ouvre pensée et là
tout le monde va s'en souvenir à pamela
anderson et se ralentit pour qu'on
puisse bien voir ses seins bougeait de
haut en bas puis pensez aussi à megan
feu
qui doit réparer une voiture est bon bah
pour réparer une voiture il faut ouvrir
le capot donc c'est l'occasion de
montrer son ventre très très plat dans
toutes ces images que je vous ai montré
à chaque fois un homme regarde le
personnage féminin et prend du plaisir à
regarder ce personnage féminin qui est
montré comme un objet et nous le
spectateur ou les spectatrices on est
associé au regard du personnage masculin
on est associé à ce désir là à son
plaisir c'est ce que laura me levais
appelle le mail guez dans un article
qu'elle a écrit en 1975
mais le melgueil ça s'arrête pas en 75
en fait ça continue et ça continue
partout c'est dans les films c'est dans
les séries si dans les pubs c'est dans
le porno c'est partout et on s'en rend
même plus compte parce qu'on a juste
pris l'habitude de voir des femmes comme
des objets passif de notre désir
alors qui sont les personnes qui créent
ce mail gay ce regard masculin
mais si on regarde juste l'industrie des
séries dans l'année 2016 2017 80% des
personnes qui étaient des shows rohner
étaient des hommes alors un show runner
c'est quoi ces les personnes qui avaient
le plus de pouvoir sur une série qui est
au dessus des scénaristes est au dessus
du réalisateur et si on regarde juste
dans game of thrones cette série que
tout le monde adore et bien sûr les
soixante treize épisodes qui ont été
diffusés jusqu'à maintenant seulement
quatre ont été écrits par des femmes et
seulement quatre ont été réalisés par
une femme
ça veut dire que le pourcentage de
création féminine à l'écriture et à la
réalisation il est de 5,4 pour cent dans
game of thrones et c'est peut-être pour
ça qu'on en arrive finalement à filmer
une scène de viol comme une scène de
sexe banal alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut se
faire face à ça si on n'a plus envie de
voir ça eh bien on peut utiliser les
réseaux sociaux et c'est ce qui s'est
passé suite à cet épisode là beaucoup de
personnes en tweets et en disant qu'il
ne voulait plus voir ce genre de scènes
de viol
les show runner ont ignoré et qu'est ce
qui se passe d'un rebelote la saison
suivante on va voir une autre héroïne
qui va se faire violer la senza stark et
nous spectateurs spectatrice on est
obligé de voir ce violent qui est d'un
point de vue encore une fois d'un voyeur
et la twitter s'est mis à rugir mais
cette fois ci beaucoup plus fort en
disant si vous continuez en fait à ce
que toutes vos héroïnes se fasse violer
comme ça on va arrêter de regarder votre
série on va arrêter d'écrire sur votre
série et la l'anecdote c'est que un des
réalisateurs a dit que les deux shows
renard on fait des petites modifications
dans les scénarii de la saison 6 et 7
alors je ne vais rien vous spoiler mais
il n'y a pas de viol d'une héroïne dans
la saison 6 et 7
bravo ça veut dire quoi
bien ça veut dire que nous on a le
pouvoir de dire ça on ne veut plus le
voir
mais maintenant c'est aux personnes qui
créent et c'est aussi aux personnes qui
diffusent et qui choisissent de ce qu'on
peut voir sur la télé de réfléchir à
l'offre qui lie à moi samedi soir
dernier quand j'étais chez moi je zappe
et à la télé et j'avais le choix entre
quoi il y avait danse avec les stars
donc des femmes en tenues à paillettes
il y avait un concert sur france 2 sur
france 3 y avait capitaine n'en
commissaire magellan qui enquêtait sur
une femme qui avait été assassiné par un
homme sur arte il y avait un
documentaire sur une famille russe du
point de vue du précepteur et sur l'a6b
y'avait ndiaye s los angeles donc
beaucoup d'autres femmes qui avaient été
aussi assassiné par des hommes
donc en fait j'avais le choix entre des
femmes à paillettes des femmes tuées ou
pas de femmes moi ce que j'aimerais
beaucoup c'est quand j'allume la télé
c'est qu'ils aient plusieurs choix et
surtout qu'on me raconte mais juste des
histoires de femmes des expériences
féminines c'est ce qu'on appellerait le
female guez le regard féminin alors vous
allez me dire non mais des héroïnes à la
télé il y en a depuis hyper longtemps
drôles de dames desperate housewife
troubles
oui oui il ya des héroïnes mais ces
séries là que je viens de citer elles
ont toutes été créées par des hommes
et c'est quoi la trajectoire de ses
héroïnes c'est soit d'avoir tout le
temps en bosses qui est un homme c'est
d'être une mère au foyer parfaite où
c'est d'essayer de rester amoureuse de
l'homme de sa vie qui est un vampire
donc il ne peut pas mourir
voilà donc en fait il n'y a pas vraiment
de choix et dans ces exemples là aussi
le problème c'est que ces femmes ces
personnages féminins elle renforce une
norme
elle renforce le patriarcat ou une femme
elle a le choix entre soit être maire ou
trouver l'homme de sa vie fin en gros
c'est toujours les ça on est juste
soumises
un homme on a envie de voir autre chose
que ça parce que ce film est il gay ce
serait justement de raconter des
expériences féminines mais qui ne ferait
pas là pour renforcer des patriarcats
qui pourraient raconter autre chose que
ces modes d'existence là alors vous
allez me dire et sex and the city mon
sex and the city c'est une de mes séries
préférées j'adore j'adore les quatre
j'adore ce qui se passe
j'adore tout sauf que banon sex and the
city non plus c'est pas du film et de
gaz alors pourquoi pas déjà carrie
bradshaw elle sa vie c'est de essayer de
faire que mr big l'aiment
mais au delà c'est un sex and the city
ça a été un moment crucial en 98 parce
que c'était la première fois qu'on
parlait vraiment des sexualité des
femmes des sexualité féminine
il y avait quelque chose de très
jouissif là dedans mais il faut savoir
que sex and the city bat ça a été créé
par un homme et ça a été chaud n'est par
un autre homme est dans la salle
d'écriture
ils ont demandé aux femmes scénariste
qui étaient là de dessiner où se
trouvait le clitoris
bah oui c'était deux hommes gays il ne
savait pas puis à plein des hommes
hétéros qui savent toujours pas mais
c'est un autre débat
alors vous voyez quand quand on a deux
hommes qui en fait n'ont aucune idée de
ce que c'est que d'avoir un clitoris et
de ce que ça peut faire sentir c'est un
peu compliqué de filmer des héroïnes
féminines qui sont obsédés par ça parce
que je suis vous repensez à cary quand
elle couche avec mister big room
charlotte quand elle découvre de rabat
et main en fait on les observe
on les regarde mais on n'est jamais avec
l on ressent pas ce petit frisson là on
les observe de loin et le female gaz ce
serait justement d'avoir cette
transition et que le spectateur ne soit
plus seulement aux observateurs et que
tout d'un coup ils ressentent ce que le
personnage féminin a dans sa peau alors
le film est gay c'est aussi et surtout
une question de regard
le mail guez bas en exemple typique
c'est quand même
james bond et la james bond girl qui
sort de l'océan alors est ce que le film
elguess ce serait là un verre c'est à
dire daniel craig qui sort de l'eau
alors vous allez me dire on a vu casino
royale il est dans l'eau il est en
maillot de bain oui mais le plan de
daniel craig dans l'eau en maillot de
bain s'arrête là mais ne descend pas
alors que si vraiment vous l inverse
c'est à dire que si on reprenait ce plan
iconiques de la james bond girl qui sort
de l'eau bah on commencerait vraiment en
filmant bas ses mollets on va prendre
quelques secondes pour l'imaginer daniel
craig est ses mollets qui serait un peu
poilu mais bronzé et musclé on leur
montrait et puis bah là il y aurait son
maillot de bain moulant et mouillée et
puis on remonterait ignoré ses abdos
dessiner puis ses pectoraux puis ce
regard bleu lagon
donc on en rêve voilà ce geste là bien
pour nous montrer que c'est un objet de
désir mais le film est le gars c'est pas
ça c'est pas une simple inversion c'est
pas de dire bon ben maintenant c'est les
hommes qui vont être les objets du désir
non le film et le gaz c'est de se dire
que
dont james bond et bats la james bond
girl à l'arrêt très d'être filmés comme
ça elle serait filmé en gros plan on
serait dans ses yeux elle aurait
peut-être même un prénom dont on se
souviendrait et puis elle aurait surtout
quelque chose à dire
parce que c'est ça en fait l'enjeu du
film et le gaz c'est d'arrêter dû
prendre du plaisir en objectifs y en
c'est de prendre du plaisir en voyant
que on a un sujet devant nous que la
femme peut être un sujet c'est prendre
ce plaisir là et alors il ya une femme
extraordinaire à hollywood qui pour moi
est en train de créer ce que ça pourrait
être le fils est il gay elle s'appelle
gilles soloway elle a déjà fait une
première série qui s'appelle
transparente qui était excellente et là
on en a co créé une deuxième avec une
autre femme qui s'appelle sarah gulbis
et cette série là elle s'appelle my love
d alors je vais pas vous traduire ce que
iluv dit que veut dire mais c'est basé
sur un livre qui portait déjà ce nom et
jay le [ __ ] et sarah green sel ont
décidé de créer une salle d'écriture qui
serait 100% féminine où il y aurait que
des femmes et ça n'était jamais arrivé à
hollywood et donc qu'est ce qui se passe
quand il n'y a que des femmes dans la
salle d'écriture qui sont en train de se
dire bon mec quatre jours d'histoire on
a envie de raconter ça donne l'histoire
donc de crise une femme d'un peu plus de
40 ans qui est en couple depuis 20 ans
avec un homme qui s'appelle silvert et
puis tout d'un coup elle va rencontrer
dec parce que dès que c'est le diminutif
de richard en anglais d'où le titre et
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ilife 10
quais bas ce qui se passe c'est que
chris tout d'un coup elle ressent du
désir un désir qu'elle avait oublié un
désir qui en ébullition et au lieu
d'avoir une histoire qui serait autour
de crise qui tromperait son mari n'en
non c'est pas ça
crise elle va dire à silvère tu sais
quoi ça y est j'ai du désir pour un
autre homme
sylvère va dire c'est génial raconte moi
et ce qui se passe à la fin de l'épisode
3 c'est que crise
elle raconte à quel point elle est
excitée par dick et du coup silvert lui
aussi les coûts' intéresse et ressent ça
et comme on est dans du film et le gaz
mais nous aussi nos spectateurs on est
avec chris donc on comprend ce qu'elle
ressent et nous aussi on va commencer à
sentir ce désir qui monte c'est ça qui
est extraordinaire c'est que tout d'un
coup ce désir féminin il va se propager
un autre exemple de female guay cc une
série peut-être dont vous avez tous
entendu parler c'est big nelo rise
c'est une série qui raconte un groupe de
femmes qui va s'allier pour pouvoir se
défendre face à un mal commun et dans
big little à il en fait une mise en
scène de la sororité cette histoire elle
est aussi basé sur un autre livre
et personne à hollywood voulait montrer
cette série personne n'était intéressé
et il a fallu que les deux comédiennes
principales nicole kidman reese
witherspoon deviennent productrice c'est
à dire qu'elles ont eu besoin d'aller
chercher de l'argent et de trouver de
l'argent pour que nous on puisse voir
cette série sur nos écrans et pour créer
cette série elles ont fait appel à deux
hommes
davidi kelly qui allait être le show
runner et puis jean marc vallée qui a
aidé le réalisateur c'est pour vous dire
que le female guez en fait c'est pas une
question du sexe de la personne qui
tient la caméra ou qui tient le stylo le
female guézy peut être créée par les
femmes et par les hommes
c'est une question de se dire qu'est ce
que je suis en train de regarder comment
est ce que je suis en train de le filmer
et qu'est ce que ça raconte parce que
c'est sûr que s'il ya plus de risques
viseur spoon et de nicole kidman s'il ya
plus de femmes qui produisent mais aussi
qu'ils écrivent qu'ils réalisent les
histoires qu'on roule quand on va voir
et qu'on va nous raconter elles vont
être différentes
et donc si elles sont différentes ça va
avoir un impact sur nous c'est évident
mais c'est la juste la première étape
maintenant il faut qu'il y ait une
deuxième étape est elle cette deuxième
étape elle se joue autour du regard
parce qu'aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
de la parole on deale libérer la parole
et moi je trouve que ce qui se passe en
ce moment c'est extraordinaire c'est
très émouvant mais c'est autant libéral
a libéré la parole autour de ces viols
fictifs dans game of thrones que dans
les viols qui se passe dans la vraie vie
ça c'est essentiel
mais dans dix ans n'aurait peut-être pas
changé si on ne libère pas non plus le
regard
il faut qu'on libère le regard parce que
c'est seulement quand on regardera
autrement qu'on pourra agir différemment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]